EU solidarity lines are great example
have our common approach can help not
only member states but third countries
as well
after Russia attacked Ukraine millions
of tons of Agriculture production were
in danger
Russia was laying mines on fields was
destroying infrastructure including
granaries both steering tractors and
other agriculture machinery
food prices sharply increased
we had to act quickly to get corn and
Grain and other agriculture production
from Ukraine to its consumers who were
highly dependent on these exports
and the EU Managed IT
we created alternative land routes and
together with black sea grain initiative
we got 25 millions of tons of Ukraine
grain of the country
and we keep going we need to improve
this process to make it faster to make
it more robust
it will help Ukrainian farmers and it
will help people around the world to buy
food for affordable price
I am glad that the EU can announce
increase of investment into this field
Global Food security cannot be hostage
of Russian aggressive politics